nous sommes sakhaline yves qu'à une
petite ville à environ trois heures de
route en temps normal en direction sud
ouest depuis kiev ces volontaires
préparent des plantages pour l'armée
d'autres envois de l'alimentation
fournie par la population locale il ya
surtout des femmes ici parce que les
hommes sont déjà déployés au fond ils
sont tous se mobilisent même mon père y
va chacun fait ce qu'il peut nous on
soutient que nous faisons ce que nous
pouvons mais si vous nous aidez pas ils
vous vous attaquez ensuite ça c'est vrai
nous voulons que l'occident nous aide
parce que l'aide est arrivée très tard
trop tard s'ils avaient introduit des
sanctions dès 2014 tout serait différent
poutine n'aurait pas déclencher cette
guerre est maintenant c'est un peu trop
tard mais mieux vaut tard que jamais
mais je mange et et nous ne pouvons
vivre sans aucun autre pays nous n'avons
donc le choix qu'entre la victoire ou la
mort j'irai me battre comme un samouraï
je serai peut-être tué mais je ne vivrai
pas sous poutine je vivrai dans un pays
libre
s'ils ont choisi cet endroit précis pour
ce travail c'est parce que dans le
bâtiment bleu derrière il y à un abri et
les tirs se font entendre parfois même
ici